I'm absolutely not playing this up for
the camera right now this is like I'm
scared I'm exhausted I'm reaching
elements
it is so hot on the roof hey we came up
with this idea to film ourselves so we
travel through the super mario galaxy we
don't know what's going to happen but we
think I know what's gonna happen do you
yeah how do you know what's going to
happen
I think it'll happen and then it happens
oh go wait Daniel day-lewis hold on this
is serious you would rather be Daniel
day-lewis at the end of there will be
blood than you right now no I'd like to
be means going back on I like know I'd
like to be me but I'd like to be in that
position telling my son you're a nobody
you know I forget to make anything of
yourself you're a loser
why would you want to tell your son that
that's like the worst thing well if it
was true rice to get himself up well but
it but don't you wouldn't you feel
partially responsible
[Music]
red ate it hard that was the way look
Joe look at the one we'll just stops I
just keep flying you have a spot on your
lens by the way I can't believe that
happened and this is for all intensive
purposes at 360 video let's just pick a
room we south the camera yeah I mean
outline where our hula hoop is we
rehearsed a few times then we recorded a
few different takes and then the day was
done completely different filming
subtlety is not going to be picked up at
all so you have to kind of over
exaggerate which again I didn't know
like I was like I didn't know either
[Music]
only when you're shooting something and
you need a clean plate you just get the
actor to move off frame but when
everything is in frame it's like where
do you go what we found earlier on is
that just running away didn't work yeah
you get smaller but you're still roughly
in the same wad rent of the circle yeah
so what you have to do is you have to
just continue walking around that that
loop the plan for today is we're gonna
go shoot the final planets first thing
in the morning here with peach what
makes that interesting is that we have
yet to actually shoot planet for I'm
having to think about how we land on the
planet 5 considering how we should be
leaving from Planet 4
it is so hot on the roof please
subscribe if you want to see more of
these videos
it is like a hundred and five degrees on
the roof we basically just jumped up on
top of a box over and over and over it's
the tree now that we finished our
meeting for fallout 4 I'm going to go
finish the day working on this little
planets video my first pass of the edit
was really slow since the video is kind
of like inherently a single shot video
even though we have several different
shots several different occasions the
entire video is essentially just one big
After Effects composition and what that
means is that you can't just edit it
like you would a normal video
picking the right news like it's super
important
[Music]
we had a lot of music issues yesterday
in the sense that we kind of didn't
really know the direction we wanted to
go with that I spent yesterday trying to
get and edit together but it's proving
to take a while getting pressure to cuz
they're like the N it needs to be done
like now I'm already past that point it
was kind of supposed to be done
yesterday and I got through the first
two planets out of five don't really
have a plan for tomorrow
well Carmack will get mad if I don't
turn this on oh my got so blue ah Here I
am at the studio on a late night all
night oh my all night I found your
jailed Carmichael I found it
now the lighting will be better why am I
here
12 X great mysteries isn't it why are we
here I'm working on this Mario video
alone and I'll probably be here through
the rest of the morning cuz there's
still a lot of work left to do an issue
half our computers don't work ideally I
could render things out an octane on a
different computer but I can't because
there's only one working computer with
octane installed I just finished the
explosion shot here see that little boom
that's why I just finished working on
trying to prioritize all the stuff that
was required for sound design because
Carmichael still has more work to do if
I don't I can't remember last time I
pulled an all-nighter on a video maybe
it was Legos maybe it was star wars
craziness has yet to set in we'll see
how we are in a few hours it's 1:00 in
the morning
Spencer's up with me he actually got the
computer finally up and running whoa
well don't quite say that yeah I mean
it's Nico Oh what are you what are you
doing I'm so now the early access video
for our patrons who support us on
patreon at the early access here they
get to see the video before anybody else
does and they usually mean seeing it
without finished effects sound of music
because we usually work on that until
the last second I just get back from the
store
I'm exactly proud of it but sometimes
you just gotta like Carmichael hey dude
why are you here I was just checking in
on you you're my buddy I just had that
maybe like 20 minutes ago I had that
sinking feeling when you realize
something's going wrong because I
realized how much work is still left to
do on this I've not touched the last
planet with peach at all yet and there's
still a few things to do including like
a cage so somehow I have to figure out a
way to have an idea
I think that'll work
I don't know what happened I'm gonna try
to put in another two or three hours and
then maybe take a nap wake up and
continue at it you might not even get a
chance to go home to get some sushi I
just need a little bit more time I had
her music
since Thursday I'm absolutely not
playing this up for the camera right now
this is like I'm scared I'm exhausted
reaching elements that's the downside to
doing a video that virtually no one's
ever done before you don't know what
sort of challenges you'll face any
export is gonna take about four hours
like it's to the point that I don't even
know if this is gonna be able to go up
Monday I really hope this video does
well
I could fall asleep right now maybe it's
not for another edible
there's so much work left what is up
with that star I fixed that the main
challenge of running into now is that
exporting this is taking about 17 hours
I still don't know how we're going to
deal with that that means
even if we were to export the final
thing right now it would still be a few
hours late that's actually a big issue
right now this can't go up tomorrow it
physically cannot like you can for every
hour now we're one hour late right
all this working was for naught okay
man poor Casey he's like hey let me know
what you think I did some stuff and I
look and it's like I received that email
six hours ago sorry dude I'm literally
just Ram previewing at like 12 fps no
that's not it at quarter res and screen
capturing it's that Carmichael has at
least something to sound design off of
I'm doing it on Sam's computer so that I
can continue working normally I'm a
pretty positive guy you know I'm pretty
optimistic but this video is turning
into a nightmare and now every hour that
goes by I fail even more what went wrong
this time is that I was doing a ram
preview of the entire thing so that we
can screen record it so that you can do
the sound design there's not enough RAM
on the computer to fit the entire video
so didn't didn't render all of it
and I'm calling Nikko and please don't
fire me come on calling is not available
we try again later
here yeah those are our questions so
we're getting into the night of Sunday
we're eating pizza thanks Sam now I'm
exporting to city form which is the best
codec for working if I had export now it
might finish before 3 a.m. I don't have
confidence Niko's going to wake up to
finish all of this these are the first
of first world problems I'm very
fortunate to have these kind of problems
but these are problems nonetheless I
apologize in advance for all the edge
issues with this quality of footage it's
really really hard to deal with sure
there's going to be glitches around like
heads in edges of planets and I'm
already an hour and a half late getting
hitting the export button up my plan was
to have this exporting by 7:00 p.m. it
is now 8:30 p.m. and I still haven't
actually got to that point moments away
from hitting that button
goes ahead 2d in the note channel this
is my burrito not touch it
okay another important thing to note I
had to basically duplicate the entire
composition to render out just the intro
it took me half an hour to like figure
out what my problem was when I added the
intro or the peach the side
[Music]
you did that Wow that's my entire
checklist look at this rendering I'm
done
yeah I thought I had the done button
kind of making on there this final
render taking about seven hours or less
and it's saying it's got another nine
hours to go it is currently 10:30 which
means by the time this is expected to
finish rendering it's going to be 7:30
in the morning that's an issue it's just
before this is supposed to go live this
is supposed to go live at 8:00 in the
morning so after this is done we've got
to bring it in to premiere and then
export it and then upload to YouTube and
then let it process on YouTube the
issues that I opened up a window
I can't touch because I literally can't
touch it I mean it's not responding
pardon me thinks that like it's going to
go up in numbers when we like yeah just
another Mario video whatever but I'm
really hoping that everyone will see it
be like I've never seen something like
this before
and share it there one was a little safe
just before I export it's like I haven't
lost any work I lost time
Jesus Christ I've I have back upstairs
I'm sure more if anyone's going to call
me out on using After Effects 2014
[Music]
Oh God same spot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
autosave doesn't autosave when you say
frequently how did that happen
[Music]
you know but yeah half of it I'm going
to run out half the video on this
computer and the other half on the other
computer I'm not even mad I'm too
relieved to be mad right now
all right I'm going to give it a couple
minutes to get some sort of time
estimation on it I guess we just got
sound design and behind-the-scenes no so
you're here for another few hours if you
want to stop rollin so you can get to it
we here at corridor digital make videos
every other week and on this channel we
document it all making videos is
challenging it's not easy especially
when you don't know what you're doing we
like to be honest in them we like to
show you all the ups and downs although
on a video like this is why more downs
than ups
alright Carmichael have a good night
[Music]
you
[Music]